et revit depuis hier soir au rythme du
festival l'air du temps pendant quatre
jours la petite commune du cher
accueille une vingtaine d'artistes et
des centaines de festivaliers de la
chanson française sur toutes ses formes
arnaud moreau et en direct du festival
bonsoir arnaud vous avez de la chance ce
soir vous êtes en bonne compagnie n'est
ce pas malgré la pluie un oui un petit
coin de paradis un petit coin de
parapluie avec camélia jordana puisque
la pluie et bien c'est invités pour
cette 24e édition du festival l'air du
temps à lignières alors avant de poser
quelques questions à camélia on regarde
tout de suite le reportage concocté hier
soir avec les groupes de constance amiot
et la maison tellier reportage concocté
par héloïse bruzat et juliette rocher
des bains douches plongée dans la
pénombre pour mettre en lumière le rock
sombre de la maison tellier pour son
premier passage à lignières le groupe
normand a choisi de livrer au public
berrichon les titres mélancoliques de
leur dernier album voter pour tous des
textes planant sublimé par des
orchestrations grave
le tout en délaissant l'anglais pour le
français un choix libérateur
ça fait de nous un projet plus
compréhensible alors qu'avant c'était
pas facile quand on en a pris conscience
de ce à quoi que c'était effectivement
la espèce de schizophrénie entre ce
qu'on faisait en anglais ce qui est ce
qu'on faisait en français pour nous ça
va c'était évident parce que on avait
l'impression d'avoir ça allait de soi
qu'on a mais avec un peu de recul
moi je comprends que c'est un petit peu
déstabilisé les auditeurs et les gens
qui écoutaient la maison télé pour la
première fois ceux qui l'écoutaient
depuis longtemps qu'il y ait là nous on
aime bien ces chansons là mais pas
celle-là ou moins là il ya c'est plus
facile à appréhender
à contre-courant des groupes actuels la
maison tellier da persiste et signe et
en français pour son prochain album un
opus dont coop a mis de côté la
fabrication le temps d'un concert
c'est à lignières
et jamais et lignières et sa salle les
bains douches n'aura aussi bien porté
son nom puisque malheureusement il ya un
petit orage pour nous accompagner
j'avais camélia jordana vous allez jouer
ce soir des extraits de votre dernier
album dans la peau parlez nous un petit
peu de cet album comment comment il a
été créé j'ai écrit une bonne partie de
l'album
et puis j'ai fait appel à babx qui est
un grand ami un immense artiste que
j'admire beaucoup qui m'a fait l'honneur
de réaliser ce second album et qui a
écrit une partie de l'album
ja on peut aussi retrouver des morceaux
un morceau de mathieu boogaert un autre
d'une grande artiste aussi qui fait
l'honneur d'assurer la première partie
en tournée qui m'accompagne sur scène
qui s'appelle achille je suis un texte
d'alice bouge tard que j'ai mis en
milliers quand ça vous fait quoi trouver
dans les endroits câline hier que
puisque le festival lâche l'un des
festivals la chanson française et je
suis très heureuse d'entendre ça fait
des années qu'on entend parler de ce
festival de ce lieu incroyable des gens
qui l'habitent et qui en trombe
cet endroit donc je suis très heureuse
qu'un média ce qu'on peut vous demander
un petit extrait d'une chanson voilà
même type même s'il pleut même pas ça va
ça va nous écrire je vais chanter une
très à-propos n'est des jours doha
je me sens liège j'imagine
les gens et les copains petit danse
étapes et les flaques les gueules plein
dedans on oran le tarn à des heures
durant je prends laura
je tue c'est jaime morales
j'aime quand le ciel gronde
monde
et que j'oublie mon âme
je prends laura
tu sais j'aime l'eau
j'aime quand le ciel gronde
que les nuages en ra
on pouvait pas rêver mieux ne pouvait
pas rêver mieux une chanson de camélia
jordana qui parle de l'orage
vous serez donc ce soir juste à côté
nous au pôle de l'âne et du cheval
un dernier mot sur vos projets
maintenant un nouvel album une continuer
la tournée je continue à tourner je suis
en festivals cet été puis je reprendrai
la tournée début octobre jusqu'à la fin
de l'année 2015
et puis après ça là à partir de mi juin
je vais tourner dans un film dont je
tient le premier rôle
un scénario magnifique donc je suis très
très heureuse de faire ça et puis je
continue à travailler enfin je commence
à écrire là en fait le prochain album
aussi bien merci beaucoup merci d'être
venu merci d'être venus malgré la pluie
on peut juste avoir le nom du
réalisateur du film pour lequel vous
avez travaillé non voilà pas je ne vous
dirai rien et vont suivre avec attention
merci camélia jordana rappelle que vous
jouez avec lio chauffe ce soir donc au
pôle du cheval et lan pour ce festival
l'air du temps à lignières et nous on se
retrouve demain midi pour un retour sur
ce concert
merci beaucoup arnaud merci à à camélia
jordana météo